your parents I mean I'm Pakistani and so
I'm going to talk on my culture they
want you to live your life according to
their terms so you're going to grow up
you're going to do all those things
you're going to get married and you're
gonna it's like a status thing as well
and it's like if you are divorced you're
bringing shame up on the family exactly
I used to struggle reading the Quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now I have like I've
seen that with the Asian Community Etc
this concept with the Somali Community
like personally myself I've realized
that they don't frown upon divorces like
they don't like this it's like it's calm
like you're married a divorcee you don't
see that with the Somali Community like
from what I've seen like with the Asians
I have seen it you're from Iraq
Kurdistan yeah because I'm curious about
turkey says yeah okay cool yeah okay
yeah okay so from your culture is it
frowned upon divorces like especially a
divorcement because this is a reality
let's be real here yeah when a woman is
divorced it's not the same when there's
a man's divorce yeah okay in Islam
they're both divorce divorce is a
divorce yeah but divorce is a divorcee
but the thing is when it comes to
um not following Islam and following
your culture as if like like I said the
woman becomes like tarnished and I'm
like where does this come from
something about what you just said that
the push that our culture gives us can
be beneficial it's a bit like say
someone criticizes you it's up to you
how you want to take it either you can
get really offended or you can act one
it so even though that is good our
culture doesn't see like that and they
don't portray it like that because when
you are young your parents I mean I'm
Pakistani and so I'm going to talk on my
culture they want me to live your life
according to their terms so you're gonna
grow up you're going to do all those
things you're going to get married and
you're gonna it's like a status thing as
well and it's like if you are divorced
you're bringing shame up on the family
exactly so I agree to that even yeah
I just want to add the fact that very
often women are double victim they are
victim from I'm talking about the one
that's been left abandoned victim of
Oppression they already victims of
whatever traumatic event they had to go
through but then this victim um an
accusation constant blame is like she's
even guilty for being victim of a
situation
I'm not I'm not talking about the one
that decided to leave family for
whatever reason that seems superficial
I'm not talking about this new trend I'm
talking about real sisters that went
through oppression that have been left
abandoned by husbands that think that
maybe he could grab someone else and
just leave his wife and kids I'm talking
about those because divorces have
different reasons different situations
about sisters that are clear victims
because everyone wants to jump on the
wagon and all sisters are victims and no
sometimes sisters need to take
accountability sometimes they are
responsible for their differences
for the wrong reasons but sometimes and
and they initiate it like statistics
show that and it's in we understand it's
in the nature but even statistics show
that rather than problem solve they will
like leave the marriage rather than
trying to I am not saying that is all
the case of sisters it's very important
we represent the real victims because
Allah has gave a strength um a position
to the husband rightfully so and
sometimes it's abused it's very
interesting you know that because I was
reading Imam Portuguese of Syria so
basically you know there's this concept
because we deal with the non-muslims ETC
like oh look at your religion it's
misogynist because a man can give talaq
about a woman can't if you look into the
city it's very interesting what he says
is that the Arabian in the Arabian
Peninsula the Arab men used to abuse
their wives by for example I divorce you
yeah she goes and she says okay no
problem I want to move on not my take it
back and there was no limit to it and
Allah set it to free talaqs to keep the
man in check because he knows and check
this out this is how beautiful Islam is
if you look at yeah free talaks is to
keep the man in check meaning you can't
stop it from moving on you've got free
if you can't control yourself and you
emotionally Let It Be guess what when
you give the first talaq what is the
ruling she has to go after the period
depends she she needs to go get married
again obviously you married and then
divorce now for a man this is very
interesting psychological yeah because
for a man to Envision his wife or
somebody else so for him if he's giving
that last talaq yeah you know
so
for a man he's thinking if I'm giving
this last Allah what it means is to
follow me my wife is Haram for me and
she will have to be with
yeah so that is put in place so he keeps
the manager even though we can say
sister yes the initiate divorce but a
real man talking about Alpha course
which people need to sign up to that you
should be a leader and control and be
like hold on a second if she's emotional
I don't need to be emotional okay come
on man be a real man so in that aspect
it's very important for us to understand
that that like who said our sisters can
be you know should be taken
accountability as well but yeah I just
wanted to put that out there because
it's a big misconception and that talaq
is a responsibility you know if if you
went to your mother your day mother and
said yeah I want to marry a sister she's
divorcy yeah bro yeah in the Asian
Community bro they'll say hell no yes
would you uh marry someone's friends
okay cool from a personal point of view
personal and cultural okay I can't oh oh
okay from a personal point of view I'll
be honest I will find it very difficult
to marry somebody who's divorced I'm
sorry I'm sorry please I'm just waiting
for someone to press the button no no no
no no
the main reason is is because
man they're going to kill me no no no no
no
yeah guys calm down basically what what
it is is I will find it very very hard I
will find it very very hard to be with
somebody knowing that she's been of
another man